one of the best performing clips on
valuetainment
i'm sorry on the pbd podcast was a
comment you made and i'm gonna give a
segue to this and you're gonna get it
rolo uh and it reminded me of the quote
the famous quote from matthew
mcconaughey in the movie um
what's the freaking movie anyway but he
goes
you know all right
dazed and confused thank you and he says
you know i keep getting older and they
say the same age
exactly so you said
a girl reaches her peak peak market
value sexual market value sexual market
value at what age did you say 25
23 23 somewhere in there okay rebecca is
like i don't think so buddy
break down what that means i feel that
no i don't feel good because being
29 now like
like you are laughing at the
ridiculousness of it but it actually is
facts and i don't know if it's just
south florida i'm jaded living there
then i lived in l.a
but all this the big markets are the
same where like the guys do really go
for the younger girls and like i feel
like i have less chance of getting
married because i'm almost 30. are you
serious yeah okay i remember in miami i
was 27
27 i just moved down and there was a
girl we were out one night she said oh
you know about kind of like the new diet
was taking over she's like we're 27. i
just started graduate school and i
realized like that's what she thought is
she was kind of at the end of the road
and i look at her
we have decided very differently about
our
lives in ourselves because but you'd you
aren't wanting like the marriage and the
kids like i am cognizant of the fact
that like
whenever i have kids i'm gonna be like
an old mom like i'm not gonna get to be
a mom while i'm young like that's just
the way
a lot of women's minds do work because
we do have the
desire to have a husband and a family so
that's where i think maybe the age thing
is
relative in my opinion this is the norm
you are not the norm you have decided no
and i mean that's a complimentary way
like
let's just clear the air you're tall
you're beautiful you're great great
personality smart like all the accolades
but
you've made a decision this is what i
talked about with the power move you're
like i don't want kids
so
the whole age thing no matter how like i
don't know if you're in your early 30s
whatever you are
you've basically said nah i don't give a
i'm not gonna play by your rules i
don't care if i get married like but the
queen victoria over here is basically in
my opinion 90 of women they want to have
when the roller all turned over you for
statistics they want to get married they
want to have kids they don't want to be
an old lady they don't want to be a
spinster they realize sometimes i am
like i could just move to europe and be
the glamorous aunt like i definitely and
then like adopt 12 cats and then you're
that lady okay but women are very very
well and
women do have
a ticking talk and if they want to have
kids
scientifically by age 32 whatever the
number is
the chances of having conception goes
yeah and break this down from the from
an age because my initial question was
sexual market value age 23 25 whatever
it is i guess well i actually want to
interrupt before you say that because
there are these like media
outlets like such as this where you're
giving this information but she kind of
is right because she chose her own
thoughts whereas like when i'm thinking
i have to get married it's because the
media has told me
are you sure about that are you sure
about that because
there's there are millennia of women who
came before you who felt the maternal
instinct just as well i agree with you
and there was a line before we had the
society we have really would you and
there were a lot of women who didn't
have birth control available so the
option was not really brought that up as
well because hormonal birth control is
actually what's contributed to a lot of
this i mean we've got two different
women right here totally different